this past weekend the new big-budget
Fantastic Four movie opened and
apparently it's a huge bomb yeah no one
went to see it now I haven't seen the
entire movie but based on the clips I'm
really surprised that the Fantastic Four
movie didn't do any better check out
this clip
[Music]
[Applause]
also auntie I think the this movie shows
a lot of emotional range in some of the
characters take a look at this moment
[Music]
[Applause]
what's he say he he looks to the heaven
and he says I think it's looking I think
you were playing that part he's chewing
food hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography